pixel opus it's a small team made up
entirely of recent graduates from to
academic gaming programs Carnegie
Mellon's entertainment Technology Center
and the San Jose State University
animation and illustration program we're
here to show you our first game in twine
it's a game about two souls who are in
love but can't be together and here
helping me done with the game are some
of the other towns and members of the
pixel ofa's team and twine features a
new twist on juicing revolves around
learning to guide two characters at once
one with each analog stick and as you
play you must negotiate addictive
sequences of obstacles that grow in
complexity and speed over the course of
nine unique lifetimes you'll have to
bring these characters together and when
you do they'll transform into an
incredible dragon
each lifetime draws to a close with your
dragon blazing a trail across the sky
with living paint and unless you create
your own aerial sculpture
and twine is a unique gameplay
experience and our team really hopes
that you'll enjoy it thank you thank God
it looks great